here for more is your hand Villa from
the German digital Association bit calm
mr. Buller if you were a youngster just
finishing off school and you're going to
university what would you study what
would be the best well at the moment I
would decide for one of the so called
mint education which means mathematic
information systems or society so the
technical xx experiences and the
technical education would be my favorite
and what do you think are going to be
the areas of fields where we're going to
have the most growing demand for humans
well one of the most growing things at
the moment is the job called data
scientist this is one who's using big
data analytics and who can program and
use it in the right way to develop new
business models for the companies ok so
we're going to need mathematics we're
going to have to be trolling through
data something that computers can do
much better than us I have to say though
yes that's correct but you still need
humans with the creativity and you still
need to say the computers what what are
the goals what do you like what do what
they have to do that's correct
ok and therefore you need still humans
ok making interactive robots as well so
not just robots that are working on
their own but working with each other
and working with us depends on being
able to copy a huge range range of
traits that that we have evolved as
humans it's incredibly complicated and
this brings us into the field of
artificial intelligence of course tell
us how far we're coming with the
software sides of things with artificial
intelligence
well artificial intelligence is one of
the most trending topics at the moment
and we will see robotics as we mentioned
just in this movie here that will you
know help us to make our human life
better to help us in operations to help
us to make our everything in your life
easier and and we have to decide what
can a computer do in the future and what
can you miss too and this is the the
most interesting question at the moment
and it's happening now in classrooms in
Japan as we heard is it going to start
happening in classrooms in Germany and
elsewhere in the world well
elsewhere and the work is correct in
Germany not we are whether there's a
study the the Pisa study for digital
education just came out in 2013 and
there we Germans did not a very well job
we are just in the the middle rankings
and and in using digital media in
schools we are just at the bottom of the
rankings so there we have to do more to
get a better educational system and to
participate on this digital age ok we'll
touch on education in a moment again but
what about retraining first of all a
huge amount of our workforce is going to
need that soon aren't they that's that's
correct in 10 years for example you need
totally different qualification to to
work in automotive sector than you need
now you need more digital competences
and this is one of the most biggest
challenges that people are on the job
has to deal with how is that being
handled by countries like Germany well
we have our dual educational system this
is a starting thing and then we have
education training on the job and every
company has to ask themself which are
the qualification that I need in the
next 10 years and how do we qualify our
people on the job ok mr. Bouie we'll
come back to you in a moment first of
all let me just bring up this one topic
at the moment many robots are programmed
to carry out a repetitive and very
specific task but we are still needed of
course when it comes to the complex
problem-solving tasks that we need
within a big industry huge projects like
shipbuilding for example they require a
lot of lateral thinking and they the
ability to juggle very different tasks
all at the same time at a shipyard in
northeastern Germany our reporter Johan
Eggers visited at a printers training to
become a construction mechanic he's one
of about 3,000 workers they're building
bigger and bigger vessels on tighter and
tighter schedules
for many it would be a dream come true
to work on cruise liners like this
Martin Cornelius is living that dream
he's been working as an apprentice at
the Maya valve shipyard since last
September Mazal from I get up at 5 a.m.
and ride to work on my bike I start at
6:30 we meet in the workshop the foreman
assigns us to an area and off we go the
17 year old could hardly wait to start
his apprenticeship the first two things
he learned wearing a helmet and
protective goggles is mandatory at all
times and secondly the shipyard is very
big he clocks are quite a few miles in a
day we'll walk through hall numbers 5 &
6 almost to the end so I can show you
where I'm working in the block assembly
and what I do there mine are McClintock
physical fitness is vital the halls are
hundreds of meters long workers at the
shipyard typically spend one year
building a cruise liner in these halls
Martin goes straight to his Foreman he
hears that today's task is to install a
porthole in one of the blocks the two
then immediately get to work the
apprenticeship runs for three and a half
years Martin is in his second year of
training
he spent his first year at a vocational
College learning all the basics we learn
how the tools work in theory and then in
practice we learn about finally how to
work with a lathe do sawing milling and
other metal work the kind of huge
passenger line is that the Maya shipyard
builds have to be constructed in stages
the work is divided into individual ship
blocks would have put together later
the construction mechanics play a key
role in all of this and that's the job
Martin is learning
he'll later be responsible for the
interior construction a multi-faceted
job that not everyone is suited to
Martin's training supervisor went
through the same apprenticeship himself
28 years ago you need a basic School
Leaving Certificate with good grades
especially in math you need to be a team
player and your work ethic and social
skills are important so is your overall
personality martin caninus is one of 270
trainees during the lunch break they all
want to know what work he was doing
while the TV crew was looking over his
shoulder he says he's spending the
afternoon on board the ship something
not everyone gets to do the workers have
to line up to be registered before they
can board the Meyer shipyard specializes
in luxury cruise liners this one is
nearly ready the trainees earn nearly a
thousand euros a month so they couldn't
afford a Caribbean holiday on one of
these ships instead they have to focus
on working hard
the shipyard is building larger cruise
liners these days and in shorter time
that means apprentices have to cope with
stress and working under constant time
pressure as the work speeds up they need
to keep pace it used to take two years
to build a ship of this size now it's
done in half that time there's no
shortage of work I'll continue my
training until my fourth year just under
two more years and then hopefully get a
job here the chances of being taken on
are pretty good the order books are full
soon the team will be starting work on
the next seagoing Giant
back with your computer from vidcom mr.
Buller we're talking about the backbone
of German industry their shipbuilding
also making cars and things like that
you come from a sect that's very
interested in digital industries in our
digital future what is going to play the
bigger part in our future here in
Germany or in the world well at the
moment we can see that our backbone
industry as you called it it comes
together with the ICT sector and this is
what we call industrial 4.0 and this is
quite interesting and the big question
is which business model is the business
model that sets the standards is the
digital business model or the classical
backbone industry and the question is a
newly open at the moment isn't it
already being answered I mean there are
lots of tech companies that are already
setting the standards aren't they yes
they are they're coming to more and more
to our industrial backbone
sectors and you can see the tech
companies are they want to produce cars
as you see Tesla in the Silicon Valley
was posing a classical car with the
electric engine and a lot of IT in the
car and they are coming to our
industrial backbone nearly close ok so
let's go back to education should we be
sending our kids then not alone a year
long to mathematics class but a coding
class as well well for example it would
be very nice and it were very good if we
do so but we don't and the German
educational system is not well prepared
for the digital age well there aren't
any coding classes to go to or what do
you say yes there are no coding clauser
for example we don't have the technical
infrastructure we don't have the
software and we don't have the people
who teach digital education and there
are other countries far far away from us
for estulin for example or the United
States so the education system here is
still about funneling the youth into
industrial jobs and into these very
basic sectors that are going to
dramatically change very soon yes there
will be change and when there are
studies that say in the next 20 years 60
percent of our jobs in Germany now 60
percent are going to be away or 2 or
even they change and our educational
system at the moment is not really good
prepare for that and we have to
this situation so what has to change
with the education system well first of
all we have to change our education
system from the basics until the to the
the high school yeah until the
university everything has to be digital
the second is we have to reform our dual
educational system we have to have more
digital components and at the third we
have to change our universities and we
have to set more digital standards there
and prepare our people better for our
labour market
I guess along with the rise of robots we
we have to develop at some stage of
working knowledge of their technology
and not just be able to interact with
them but actually understand what
they're going through to do whatever
they're doing for us yes we have we have
to deal with these robotics on one hand
on the other hand we have to focus on
our human on our human talents like
creativity or social aspect for example
there will be a lot of jobs in the
creativity sector or in the in the
health sector for example pH where you
have to deal with people and people
dealing with people is the people's job
and it will be a people's job even if
robotics are there and just lastly when
you're talking about changing the
education system and changing the way we
think and how our industry is changing
what about investment how is that
changing because that is really going to
play a big role here well West thing is
changing at the moment and again not in
the classical industry sector but in the
ICT sector if they're if you see the
most worth companies in the world in the
top five are all digital companies and
this is where the future is going to be
mr. piller thank you very much for
coming in today thank you very much